je suis brigitte apsit j'ai
56 ans bientôt à la retraite je suis
enseignante de profession
je suis élu depuis 2014 à la mairie de
trois-bassins réélu en 2000 le vin dans
les mêmes fonctions c'est le d'adjointe
aux affaires scolaires qu'au département
je suis dans la commission des
solidarités et de la cohésion sociale
je suis élu sur le canton xiv un canton
qui s'étale sur deux communes celles de
trois bassins et de saint leu donc je
suis bien évidemment attaché à ce canton
parce que j'estime que c'est un canton
un potentiel touristes et que
sous-exploité dont il ya des choses à
faire sur le plan touristique
et puis un canton avec des
problématiques
sociales qui se ressemblent sur les deux
villes
de par mon métier je suis
quotidiennement confrontés aux problèmes
des familles du coup un accompagnement
social de ces familles pour un meilleur
vivre une amélioration de leur cadre de
vie de leurs difficultés qui se sont
accrus avec la crise sanitaire donc ça
va être une priorité pour moi en tant qu
élue aux affaires scolaires à la mairie
de trois-bassins je suis souvent
interpellé par le cheminement piéton qui
n'existe pas sur une portion de route
pour les élèves d'une école pas
seulement les élèves l'ailé les parents
les gens qui empruntent cette portion de
route depuis six générations dans six
années que l'on ne peut plus aller à la
piscine de vue belle puisque nous
dépendons de
vue belle pour l'enseignement de la
natation dans les écoles
du coup vu que cette piscine est fermée
depuis six ans on n'a plus le moyen d'
apprendre à nos enfants à nager donc ce
serait bien que le département puisse
nous offrir des bassins de baignade j'en
ferai un combat
notre collège mérite également d'être
rénové il y aurait aussi à faire dans le
domaine agricole un gros travail sur les
les chemins qui mènent aux exploitations
l'habitat l'habitat c'est un gros souci
les problèmes de moisissures les
problèmes d'infiltration d'eau c'est un
problème récurrent nous le canton est
une grosse partie de sa population qui
vit dans les eaux donc faire en sorte
que nos familles puissent avoir un
logement
décent ça va être aussi un de mes un de
mes combats
une des missions premières du
département c'est sa mission sociale du
coup je trouve que jusqu'à présent elle
n'a fait que se perfectionner dans sa
politique de proximité qu'elle continue
dans cette voie qui continuent à porter
à développer sa politique en faveur des
familles défavorisées
des personnes porteuses de
handicap qu'elle continue sa politique
d'infrastructures routières au niveau
des collèges puisque c'est de sa
compétence
donc moi je trouve que jusqu'à présent
le département a fait du très bon boulot
pour améliorer le cadre de vie de tous
les réunionnais du coup qu'elle continue
sur cette voie et nous les nouveaux élus
bien on va s'attacher à ce que à
apporter notre pierre à l'édifice pour
aider au mieux le département à
développer sa politique de
d'amélioration de vie des gens